Good morning.
Welcome to the session on
Mobile Web Performance Auditing.
If you can see past the
glare of lights on bald,
you'll see that that's
what I look like.
You can find me on Google+
as Paul Lewis and on Twitter
as @aerotwist.
Hey Paul, would you mind
a performance audit?
This is what my
colleagues would say.
Or if they're feeling
particularly urban that day,
'sup, Paul?
The point here is
that over time, people
have asked me to figure
out whether something
is fast or not.
And so, I've built
up, over time,
a way of figuring that out.
And that's what I wanted
to share with you.
So maybe you find
yourself in this situation
where people are asking you
to do more performance work
and you're wondering how
you should go about it.
Welcome.
This is what we're
going to talk about.
Good.
So, the first question
is why even bother?
What's the point?
Well, as you probably
gathered from all the sessions
that we've been doing,
smartphones are on the rise.
Which isn't to say there's
going to be a rebellion-- I just
mean that more people
are using them.
And one study reckons that just
over 1/3 of American adults
are using their smartphone
as their primary means
of internet access.
As Paul Irish said
in his session,
that means that the first
experience that somebody
has of you and your brand is
going to be on their phone.
This trend isn't just America.
It is actually further afield.
This is the global
internet traffic percentage
for mobile is on the way up.
It's just crossing the 30% mark.
Sometime in the
middle of next year,
if the trend line is to be
believed, we will cross 50%.
That will make it the majority.
The thing about these devices,
more people are using them,
but they're performance
constrained.
If you have a performance
problem on your desktop,
when it hits the
mobile device, it's
going to be really painful.
And if you're asking yourself
whether this is a big deal,
let's just cover the
stats very quickly,
a couple that are interesting.
A 200 millisecond
delay to Google results
cause a 0.3% loss in engagement.
This is a study that
we did a few years ago.
But if you like your
stats a little bit more
on the positive side, this
is what Etsy had to say,
Lara Swanson from Etsy.
She said, when we
eliminated jank--
and we'll talk about that in a
little bit-- on Etsy's activity
feed, we saw people
favorite it more often
and favorite more things, which
is a sort of meta indicator
for conversions, really.
So, performance matters.
Or as I like to say,
hashtag, perfmatters--
which you can track along with,
or you can get the sticker.
I've actually got stickers.
Come and get a sticker.
You can wear it like a
badge, put it on your laptop,
put it on somebody
else's laptop as
a passive aggressive measure.
Just, you know, don't want
to call it out, but yeah.
But the thing about
mobile, as well,
is that because the browser is
the only thing that people have
on the screen at
that time, they have
these really high expectations--
in the way they also
interact with it.
With the touch, you
feel the latency
in a way you don't
necessarily feel with a mouse.
So not only are these devices
performance constrained,
but people have
higher expectations.
Yay.
And you might ask yourself
the question, well, isn't it
the browser's job to
make things go faster?
And the answer is,
yeah, absolutely.
And from a Chrome point of
view, we have, and we are doing,
and we will continue
to make things faster.
This is something that we
take very, very seriously.
However, there is a
whole suite of things
that we, as developers,
get to control
and we get to decide
for our sites and apps.
And so this is where
the audit comes in.
Because it's really
talking about the things
that we get to
control and how we
can make sure that we're
working with the browser
rather than against it.
So, what then does the
performance audit look like?
Well, for me, it
falls into two parts--
the page load, how quickly did
we get something on the screen?
And then, once it's on the
screen, how well did it run?
Were the scrolling, the
animations, interactions,
were those all fast?
So we'll step through
it bit by bit.
We'll start off with page load.
Now, the first tool I
always go to on the audit
would be this,
PageSpeed Insights.
All you do is you pop in your
URL like so, hit Analyze.
It's really complicated.
And ta-da, you get a
score out the other side.
You get a score for desktop,
you get a score for mobile,
and it'll give you some
user experience hints
as well, like top targets,
legibility of your text,
and so forth.
So, if you've got problems
that might not be obvious
when you look at your
device and you run it,
then this will start to
pick them out for you.
People ask what kind of
scores they should get.
These are my own
personal scores.
85 on mobile, 90
on desktop, and I
don't want to see any UX issues.
You could disagree with these.
I would recommend that you going
and have a look at what you're
actually getting as your scores.
I tend to say that if you're
getting in this range,
you haven't got any
major issues there.
But what kind of things
are we looking for?
Well, I'm going to go to
blast through what I consider
to be the bread and butter,
the things I think we've talked
about time and time again as
developers over the years.
First one is unoptimized images,
because unoptimized images
are going to waste
your mobile data.
And as somebody who's roaming
in the States right now,
I'm very acutely aware
of my carrier back
home and the charges they
could levy against me if I were
to download something
that was very large.
But it also increases
site load time.
63% according to
HTTP Archive-- that's
the percentage of bytes
in the average web
page that are images.
So it represents this huge
surface area of optimization
that we can go after as well.
Easiest way I know, if
you have this problem,
is just drag them onto
ImageOptim if you're on a Mac--
there are equivalents
for Windows, I'm sure.
And it will go through, it
will crush the images down,
spit them out, and
you're way better.
Unminifed resources-- so
things like your JavaScript
and your CSS, they
also waste data,
and they will increase
your site load time.
We've talked about this,
I think, as an industry
for a long time.
So it's on my list because
this is what I look for.
But all the same, I
would say it's something
that I would expect
everybody does already.
Anyway, the one I don't think
that many people think about
is the number of requests.
Or maybe they do, but let's
talk about this a bit.
Every request that you're going
to make-- JavaScript, CSS,
images-- they're going
to slow down your site.
So that should also
be on the list.
And now we go into
what I consider
to be the bonds that are, I
suppose, more mobile concerned.
This one-- too many redirects.
Not something that I think
people think about initially,
but let me explain why.
Every redirect that
you make is going
to slow down somebody
on their phone.
And 40% of people apparently
will abandon your site
if it takes longer
than three seconds.
So I've taken the liberty
of putting a timer here.
If we request this site,
and it's your site,
we incur the cost of
DNS and a connection
and sending some data.
And on 3G, we will be talking
potentially up to a second
to get this done.
If we respond by saying
actually what you're
looking for is on
the m. site, we now
have to do another DNS look
up, make another connection,
and send more data.
And we're potentially
into that two seconds.
And then we say
actually what you really
wanted was on this path.
We don't have DNS
this time, but we
do have a connection
and data, and all
of a sudden we're
starting to get perilously
close to the three
seconds, and all we've done
is show a white screen.
This is bad and something
that we want to avoid.
Shock upon shock,
the solution is
to actually respond
to the request.
And if that sounds like a sort
of roundabout way of saying
m. sites might be
bad, yeah, you might
think that this is an easier
way to solve that problem.
So on my list of things, and the
things the PageSpeed Insights
will also give you back,
is avoiding redirects.
So far, so good.
We have this kind
of list of things,
this checklist of things.
But we don't really
know what it's
like to load the site
from a real world
location on a particular
device and so forth.
That is where WebPageTest is
going to come in and help us,
and it is not very
complicated to set up.
Here we go.
Pop the URL in in the
top, and we ask it
for a particular
location and browser.
And we say in this
case I want 3G.
Number of tests.
And because I'm
feeling exciting,
let's capture a video as well.
That's one of the
amazing features.
I love capturing videos.
We're going to look
at that one in a sec.
So we run this, and we
get some results back.
And at first glance,
I always think
this is a bit overwhelming.
So let's dive into
what we're seeing.
Performance grids
in the top corner,
these are like
the headline items
of what you should
be looking for.
If you get reds in
here, that's something
that you want to look
for and you want to fix.
So if you click on
it, it will tell you
why you got the grade
you got and what
you need to go away and fix.
The next thing we get are
the performance details.
You know, how long
did it take our server
to start sending
data back, how long
did it take for the page
to render, everything
that you need from a
numbers point of view.
We also get a waterfall
and a few charts.
And then because I checked
that Capture Video button,
I also get this in the corner,
which says Watch Video.
So I thought I'd share a video
off my-- I made this test
site, by the way.
It is hideous, but
I did it to show.
It's not that I did
this on purpose.
Well, I did do this on purpose.
Anyway, have a look.
Well, I hope that was
as agonizing for you
as it was for me, frankly.
18.2 seconds to load
something on a 3G connection.
I've pulled out the
three milestones
that I think are
dead important here.
First of all, 6.5
seconds-- that's
the point at which we've started
to get something on screen.
Up to that point, all we
had was a white screen.
And, as we discovered
earlier, up to three seconds
for everything, and
people start leaving.
So that's bad.
9.7 seconds is when we actually
had the initial viewport filled
in, and that's something we'll
come back to in a second.
And then lastly,
when everything's
loaded at 18.2 seconds, we can
consider ourselves complete.
So this one here-- saying that
something is visually complete
is actually a really
interesting measure,
because it represents
something to do with perceived
performance and how
people feel how long it
takes to load your site.
And when we go back
into those results
that we have from WebPageTest,
the one number that
should stand out for
us then, is this,
which is that 9.7
seconds expressed
as milliseconds-- pretty much.
There is a bit of difference.
The speed index is a
really good measure
for perceived performance.
It's actually a link.
You can click on it.
It will tell you
how it figures out
what the speed index should be.
And it is a bit
convoluted, but it
does represent the best
measurement that we
have for perceived
load, not just
the body on load kind of
event, which as we saw
was several seconds later.
When I'm doing my
audits, I tend to look
for a speed index of
around about 1,000,
which is a very tricky number,
difficult number to get,
but it's actually a
really valuable one.
That's going to make your site
feel really snappy to anybody
who loads it, particularly
on a mobile connection.
Also worth pointing out is
because I checked that Capture
Video button, I have
this filmstrip view.
And if we look at that, it's
pretty much like that video I
showed, I suppose, in many ways.
But you have the white
screen there at 6 seconds.
You have visually
completed about 10.
And it's basically
up to this point,
up to this 10 seconds, is what
we call the critical rendering
path.
This is the point where we
have to figure out, well,
what does the browser need in
order to get things on screen?
And that comes in two parts.
It's what information
does it need,
and then how can we stop it
being blocked in doing that?
So for example, JavaScript can
block rendering, as an example.
The thing you want to
do is to prioritize
the critical rendering path.
You want to make it
easy for the browser
to get something on screen.
That will lower
your speed index,
and it will make your
site feel a lot snappier.
Prioritizing the
critical rendering path
is a big topic,
too big for this.
So I will point you towards
the Google Web Fundamentals,
which we recently launched.
I've created a short
link there, if you care,
for taking that down.
Bit.ly/io-crp.
There we go.
That is a whole
documentation on how
you can prioritize the
critical rendering path.
Looking at the
waterfall that we get,
first thing is those redirects.
PageSpeed Insights will have
told us that we had redirects.
This is going to confirm that.
And each one of those, you
can see, slows us down.
The other thing I thought
was quite interesting--
in my fake example-- is
that I'd duplicated files.
I've requested jQuery twice.
But I know that
this is perfectly
reasonable and possible,
having seen it in the wild,
that you have
multiple developers,
one pulls in jQuery, the
other one pulls in jQuery,
and whoops, didn't realize
we were getting it twice.
If you look at your
waterfalls, you
might start to see
those kinds of patterns.
The other thing I
noticed is that we've
spent a long time
transferring one
of the images, that dark blue.
Most of the time,
it's not actually
spent transferring bytes.
It's actually all the
different connections,
and so forth-- which
comes back to the number
of actual requests.
But in this case, we do
have a long transfer time.
So far, so good.
This is the page load.
So it's optimizing
resources, reducing
the number of requests,
it's avoiding redirects,
and it's prioritizing the
critical rendering path.
And I think most people, when
they hear that, they go, fine,
but that sounds
like a lot of work.
Yes, it can be.
But there's good news.
Grunt and Gulp both have tasks
galore to help you do this.
And so all you need to do is
just run them with these tasks,
and it will hopefully help you.
In fact, when I ran
through this talk,
my colleagues went,
I need the closure.
They don't sound like that.
That's me doing a mean
impression of them.
And so I said, OK, fine.
This is me running Grunt.
Eight whole seconds
later, ta-da.
And now my PageSpeed
Insight score is 100.
But really, when
somebody loads it,
you'll notice that the speed
index has dipped to 1396.
Just following PageSpeed
Insights' guidance,
following
WebPageTest's guidance,
will help you significantly.
In this case, we're
6.8 times faster.
Yay for me.
But--
[APPLAUSE]
Wait, no, I made it seven
times slower on purpose.
That's all good.
So that's page load.
For me, it's those
kinds of things.
The bit where I normally kick
in is this bit, the runtime,
because for me, I
get very frustrated,
even when something
loads quickly,
if it is horrible
to actually use.
And other people
notice that as well.
Let's come back
to what Lara said.
When we eliminated jank, better,
better, more, more, brilliant.
OK?
Jank.
Jank is missed frames.
But then you go,
hang on a minute.
What's a frame?
Exactly what are we
talking about here?
Yeah, let's set this one out.
Your modern smartphone
refreshes its screen
about 60 times a second.
For us, then, we actually
have to get 60 pictures
or 60 frames onto the screen.
And that means that
for that one second,
we will have 16 milliseconds in
which to create those pictures.
And so it becomes very
important to understand
how those pictures
are made and how
we control that part of the
process, because we really,
really do.
So let's talk about how Chrome
goes about making a frame.
This is the Chrome 1.
To be honest, most browsers
actually go through
a very, very similar
process, but this
is the Chrome specific bit.
The first part of the process
from a developer's point
of view is the
recalculation of style.
Here we've got a DOM tree.
I've simplified it a little bit.
There's nothing under head.
There normally would be.
But you get the idea.
We have a DOM tree.
We've parsed our HTML,
we've created this tree,
and what we do is
we bring in the CSS
that we have from
the style sheets
the user agent.
And what we start doing
is we start saying, OK.
This applies to these
elements, and some of it
will cascade down.
This from the user agent
actually switches off the head,
because we don't display that.
Same goes for scripts, and
so on, and so on, and so on.
The browser does it
faster than I would.
Till we arrive at this.
This a new tree
called a render tree,
and it's all the things that we
care about putting on screen.
So we have this tree, and we
know all the things about,
in theory, the colors
and the positions
and how everything relates
to everything else.
Now we actually have to figure
out the geometry of the page,
and we call this layout.
So we push this in.
And I marked it out with boxes.
This is where we think all
the elements are going to be.
And the thing about
this part of the process
is the unique-ish
layout model of the web
means that one thing can
affect another thing.
If I change the height
or the width of the body,
then the things that
are inside the body
are probably going
to be affected.
So it starts to
matter about how we
start to deal with
our elements as
to whether layout
will be a problem.
Next, we actually have to
start filling in some pixels.
So let's start with our boxes.
Let's fill it in white, pop in a
header, a couple of UI elements
there, some buttons,
put a bit more text.
Hamburger icon-- argue with
whether that's a good thing.
User experience
people aren't so sure.
Title, date, and we're good.
We've filled in our picture.
We've had this one
bitmapping memory
that we've drawn
our pixels into.
Super.
The final part of the
process that we care about
is compositing.
Now, to understand
compositing we actually
have to go back
to Paint a second.
Where-- let's say we've
got a different header
that we want to put in.
Let's say we're fading
between that darker
one to that brighter one.
Well, this area in red
is considered dirty.
And so we paint
in our new header.
But now we actually have
to repaint the hamburger
icon, the title, and the date.
And you start to sort of
say, hang on a minute.
That's not great.
Because we've had to
paint a bunch of things
that didn't even change.
Well, the good news is we
can and we do do better.
What we actually do is we create
these things called compositor
layers.
So these things are in
separate space in this picture,
but really, you can see
the header is animating all
by itself.
And we have this
separate layer that we've
painted all the
other content into.
The idea is now we can
keep them separate.
And when we're
repainting, we don't
have to repaint the
things that didn't change.
So that's compositing.
The good news is
that Chrome DevTools
will show you frame data.
If you load up DevTools
and go to the timeline tab,
you can see something like this.
This is zoomed in.
The things that we
care about is there's
this line here at the top that
marks the 30 frames a second.
This one is 60 frames a second.
And you see here, when
you're running your page
and this is recording,
you'll start
to see these bars up here.
This is your page's
frames per second.
And when we zone in
on one of these bars,
we start to see these
records appear at the bottom.
And they correspond
to that pipeline
that we just discussed.
Recalculating style,
what applied to what,
what CSS applied
to which elements.
Layout, figuring out the
geometry of the page.
Paint, filling in the pixels.
And of course, compositing
putting all those layers
back together.
So now that we know about
how Chrome and other browsers
create frames, I would
like to introduce you to,
my friends, the four
horsemen of The Jankocalpyse.
These issues are my greatest
hits, as it were, of jank.
That's not to say they will
occur in every project,
but they're the things
that I'm looking
for when I do the audits.
And they're as follows.
Firstly, expensive animations.
And you should consider
scrolling to be an animation.
Something is moving on screen.
Let's take a pretty innocent
looking example, I suppose.
Let's assume we're making
a card-based system,
because that's pretty
popular on mobile.
And we have this expanded class.
We tap, say, one of these
cards, and we expand it out
to 400 pixels in height.
And we're going to just do a
CSS animation, because we've
heard that that's good--
or a CSS transition, that's
also good.
It turns out that this isn't
quite as good as we'd hoped.
And to understand why,
what we're going to do
is notionally we're going to
plug in our Nexus 5 into out
machine over USB.
We'll go to Chrome Inspect.
And you'll start to see
that the tabs appear
that we have opened.
I have an animation on
layout tab open here.
And all we need to do is tap
Inspect or click Inspect,
and we'll start
bringing up DevTools.
So we have our card example
here, we have DevTools,
and the little red light
says that we're recording.
And when I tap on one of these
cards to expand it, boop,
you'll see that we've
shot out the top of that--
even the 30 frames
a second line.
And when we click
on it, we find out
that we've spent 23
milliseconds figuring out
the geometry of the page.
Because as we expanded
one of those elements,
we had to move all
the other ones down,
and we had to figure out what
happened to the geometry.
And that was expensive
on a mobile device.
You'll also notice that we
spent nearly 600 milliseconds
painting the pixels.
So when we're supposed to
be doing 60 milliseconds
in a frame, to
spend 600 is going
to kill out frames per second.
So this, for your users,
will appear as janky.
Because this is one situation,
it's not always the case.
But generally speaking,
I tend to find
that layout will trigger these
kinds of performance problems.
But you can see how
you start to figure it
out yourselves with
Chrome DevTools.
So, from a kind of
frames point of view,
if we go to these 16
millisecond markers,
that layout, even
just the layout,
pushed us past that marker.
And now the paint just
killed everything for us.
And it's not much better if
you go straight to paint.
I have a bit of code here
that's going to send something
to hot pink-- why wouldn't you?
And again, we're going
to use a CSS transition.
Similar kind of
situation-- let's
have a look at what we see
when we run it in DevTools.
Tap it.
Boop.
And you can see,
again, we're not
even hitting 60 frames a second.
In fact, here we are.
72 milliseconds just
painting each of those.
Again, you might find
that that's not always
going to be the problem for you.
But even so, it's probably
worth figuring out the tools.
Do excuse me.
There we go.
Failure to plug in.
There we are.
Please tell me that I
didn't kill something.
Oh, I'm back
Thank you so much.
OK, good.
Whew!
Leave it alone.
All right, so you might
be asking yourselves
how can we get high performance
animations on a mobile device?
Great question.
And the answer is
to stick to these,
actually-- is to stick to
transforms and opacity changes.
So the transforms
obviously translate scale.
Here we are.
And it'll pass through there.
Now, the only note there
is that the element
will need to be on its
own composite layer,
just like the header
that we had before,
which was on its own layer.
And you might be
saying, well, OK, fine.
How does something
get its own layer?
Great, OK.
Well, there's a new
property that is in Firefox,
and it's in Chrome, it's
currently in Canary,
I believe-- is will-change.
And will-change,
you can tell it's
about the things that
are going to change
from a visual point of view,
like transform, in this case.
Or you can tell yoy it about
something like opacity.
You could use left,
top, depending
on what it's going to change.
And you're now
trusting the browser
to create composite
layers or just make
the right optimization for you,
and that's a really good thing.
One kind of note
of caution here is
that if you create too
many compositor layers,
you could find that
your time in compositing
goes through the roof.
So that's something to watch
for in terms of those records
that you see in DevTools.
So let's go back and see
what happens when we just
animate transform and opacity.
Here we go again.
Here we go.
A very smooth 60 frames a
second is what you'd experience.
And you'll notice that we spend
a fraction of a millisecond
recalculating each of the
frames of our animation
and then a fraction of a
millisecond compositing things
together.
People often say, well, how come
I'm seeing transparent bars up
here in DevTools?
And the answer is, essentially
those frames are empty.
The workload was so light to
do compositor based operations
compared to doing layout and
paint that we can now fit it
comfortably inside the 60
frames a second budget.
So from a frame point of
view, we recalculated style,
we did compositing--
all was well.
So in terms of this
kind of waterfall,
we would like to
be down here, is
the long and the
short of it, rather
than starting right up,
say, at the top with layout
and then paint.
So then, having explained all
that, the first item on my list
is am I seeing
expensive animations?
If so, I will start to
suggest that people restrict
their animations to
these properties.
The next thing I see quite
often is mistimed animations.
It's still true,
I believe, today
that jQuery uses setInterval
for its animations.
And the problem that you
have when you use setInterval
for your animations
is that you'll
find that your JavaScript,
your setInterval
fires at some point
inside your frame.
And sometimes you'll
miss your frame,
and sometimes you'll
hit your frame.
But for your users,
what they'll see
is they'll see jitter and jank.
What you should be doing instead
is using RequestAnimationFrame
because it gives you this.
It gives you a consistency on
the scheduling, the knowledge
that you are going at
the start of the frame
and much more likely to
hit your happy point.
So the second
thing I look for is
sane use of
RequestAnimationFrame.
Layout thrashing continues
to be an interesting one.
And what this is, let's take
a fairly contrived but fun
example.
We'd like to resize all
these paragraphs to be
the same width as this
blue block here, like so.
And the code for this, I
think, would be pretty trivial.
We'd look through
our paragraphs,
we ask for the width
of the blue block,
and then we set the
first paragraph.
And we go around
the loop and we ask
for the width of the blue block,
and we set the second one.
And if you run
DevTools against this,
you'll start to see something
that looks like this.
The first thing to
notice is that we
have a monster frame, which
is about 2.65 seconds.
When we look into the records
of why it was a monster frame,
you start to see that we've
gone into this bizarre cycle
of reading and writing styles.
And what's actually
happening is we
are asking for the
width of the blue block,
and then with doing something
to invalidate that calculation
by setting the
paragraphs' width.
DevTools actually puts
this yellow triangle.
And this is a warning
to you, which--
it's going to call it a
Forced Synchronous Layout
operation, which is
its way of saying,
you made me go away and do
some layout calculations,
figure out the
geometry of something,
its width, its height,
its padding, its margin,
when I wasn't expecting to.
Are we're going into this kind
of thrashing between the two
states.
Instead, what we should do is
ask for the layout property
once at the start and
then do all the writing.
So as a kind of
more general rule,
when I see a layout
thrashing, I would
say, read any layout
values, then write them.
That said, if you're
going for the first one,
you'll probably try and avoid
layout during an animation.
And the last thing I look
for, the fourth horseman
of the Jankocalypse,
is garbage collection.
Garbage collection
has the ability
to essentially
interrupt at any point.
It's an indeterminate point
in your frame's life cycle.
When we switch over to the
memory in DevTools, the memory
profiler, you see here we
have one of these drops.
So we see this chart of memory
going up and down, up and down.
Every time it goes down,
that's garbage being collected.
In this particular situation,
I have a large amount,
about 40 megabytes of
garbage, so stuff that
has been released.
And it takes Chrome
10 milliseconds.
Now, this has actually got a lot
faster over the last few years.
But it can still
knock you off in terms
of your frames per second.
Oh, it hurt.
And this is why.
Basically, it's something
you don't have control
over in that sense of when
this is going to happen.
But if it does happen
to you then you
will not make your
60 frames a second.
So writing fast memory
efficient JavaScript
is a big topic in and of itself.
And so I will just
point you to this,
which is Addy Osmani's article
by that very same name.
I like the fact that Addy's not
even looking at anybody here.
He's just aloof, doesn't
want to look at us.
All right, good.
Runtime, then-- for me,
it's restricting animations
to transforms and its opacity.
As I said, these aren't
always going to crop up,
but this is what
I'm looking for.
It's the sane use of
RequestAnimationFrame.
It's reading layout values and
then writing them if necessary.
And it's writing faster
memory efficient JavaScript.
As I said, these aren't
always going to crop up,
but when they do,
these are the things
that are going to
stop it feeling
silky smooth on a mobile device.
So far, though, this is what
I've spent my time looking at.
So like I said at the
start, the feature
that we face is with these
things, with smartphones.
And they are
performance constrained.
When you hit a
performance issue,
you really know about it.
And people have
higher expectations
of performance on mobile.
Bizarrely, they do.
And so we really need to
meet that expectation.
We really need to make fast
performing sites and apps.
The way you're
going to get there
is to start by gathering data.
The tools that I've shown--
PageSpeed Insights, Chrome
DevTools, WebPageTest-- they
should be the bread and butter.
You should go away
and run those,
and see if you can figure
out what's happening.
But the tools themselves
will let you gain insight.
They will actually tell
you what the numbers mean,
why you got the scores you
got, and what you should do.
This is PageSpeed
Insights saying,
here are all the reasons why I
think you have illegible text.
And if I fix all
these, I'm good.
Which is to say, the
final part of the puzzle
is to take action.
It's no use getting all this
information, all this data,
and then doing nothing with it.
So if I can ask
you to do one thing
it would be to go
forth and audit.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Let me know what you think
with the session feedback,
and I will be outside
for Q&A after this.